양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 디렉터예요. 이번은 시리즈의 14번째 강의이고, 양자 오류
정정을 다루는 네 번째 단원의 두 번째 강의예요. 지난 강의에서는 9 qubit Shore 코드를 포함한 양자 오류 정정을 처음으로 살펴봤고, 그것이
이론적으로 양자 오류 정정이 가능하다는 걸 보여줬어요. 또한 오류의 이산화에 대해서도 논의했는데, 이를 통해
qubit에서의 임의적인 양자 오류를 비트 플립과 위상
플립으로 효과적으로 투영함으로써 정정할 수 있어요. 이번 강의에서는 안정자 형식론에 대해 논의할 거예요. 이건 수학적 도구인데,
안정자 코드라고 알려진 광범위한 종류의 양자 오류 정정 코드를 명세하고 분석하는 데 쓰여요. 여기에는 9 qubit Shore
코드뿐만 아니라 실제 양자
컴퓨팅 장치에 훨씬 더 적합할 것으로 보이는 코드들을 포함한 다른 많은 예시도 포함돼요. Shore 코드만큼 모든 양자 오류 정정 코드가 안정자 코드인 건 아니지만, 많은 게 그래요.
이 시리즈에서 살펴볼 모든 예시를 포함해서요. 분명 흥미롭고 잠재적으로 유용한 양자 오류
정정 코드 중 안정자 코드가 아닌 것들도 있지만, 그것들은 꽤 더 복잡한 경향이 있어요. 어쨌든
안정자 형식론이 양자 오류 정정의 토대에서 핵심적인 부분이라는 건 의심할 여지가 없고, 우리는
단원의 나머지 부분에서 이것에 크게 의존할 거예요. 강의의 간략한 개요를 소개할게요. 먼저 짧은 논의부터 시작할 거예요.
Pauli 행렬과 Pauli 행렬의 텐서 곱에 대해서인데, 이것들은 qubit에 대한 연산뿐만 아니라
qubit의 측정도 나타낼 수 있어요. 제가 설명할 거고, 이 맥락에서 우리는 종종 이것들을 관측량이라고 불러요. 그런 다음 반복 코드를 다시 살펴보고
Pauli 연산과 관측량을 통해 어떻게 설명할 수 있는지 볼 거예요. 그게 안정자 코드에 대한 일반적인 논의로 이어지는데
다양한 예시, 안정자 코드의 기본 속성, 그리고 인코딩, 오류 감지, 오류 수정이라는
기본적인 작업들을 어떻게 수행하는지를 포함해요. 강의는 Pauli 연산에 대한 간략한 논의로 시작할 거예요. 주로 안정자 형식론의
기초를 마련하기 위해서지만, 몇 가지 핵심 사실을 확인하고 기본 용어를 정립하기 위해서이기도 해요. 먼저 Pauli
행렬인데요. 안정자 형식론을 위해서이기도 하지만, 몇 가지 핵심 사실을 관찰하고 기본 용어를 정립하기 위해서예요. 먼저 Pauli
행렬에는 2x2 단위 행렬과 세 개의 비단위 Pauli 행렬이 포함돼요. 이것들은
시리즈 나머지 내내 대문자 X, Y, Z로 표기할 거예요. 이 네 행렬은 모두 유니터리이면서 에르미트이고,
오류뿐만 아니라 수행하기로 선택한 연산을 포함해서 qubit에 대한 연산과 연결 지을 수 있어요.
지난 강의에서 논의했듯이, 비단위 Pauli 행렬 X, Y, Z는 서로 반교환해요.
즉, XY는 -1 * YX와 같고, XZ는 -ZX와 같으며, YZ는
-ZY와 같아요. 곱셈을 해보면 이 관계들을 쉽게 확인할 수 있어요. 이 반교환
관계들은 매우 단순하지만 안정자 형식론과 다른 곳에서 결정적으로 중요해요. 구체적으로
곱에서 서로 다른 두 비단위 Pauli 행렬의 순서를 바꿀 때 나오는 이 마이너스 부호들은 안정자 형식론에서의 오류
감지에 정확히 대응해요. 또한 여기에 곱셈 규칙도 나열했는데, 각
Pauli 행렬은 그 자신의 역행렬이에요. 이건 그것들이 유니터리이면서 에르미트라는 사실과 일치하고, 서로 다른 두 비단위
Pauli 행렬을 곱하면 항상 나머지 비단위
Pauli 행렬의 플러스 또는 마이너스 i배가 나와요. 특히, 전역 위상을 제외하면 Y는 X 곱하기 Z와 동일한데, 이게 양자 오류 정정에서 x와 z 오류에 초점을 맞추는 이유예요.
X는 비트 플립을 나타내고, Z는 위상 플립을 나타내며, 전역 위상을 제외하면 Y는
같은 qubit에서 이 두 오류가 동시에 발생하는 걸 나타내요. 이 네 행렬은 모두
단일 qubit에 대한 연산, 오류, 또는 오류가 없는 상태를 나타내지만, 여러 qubit에 대한 연산이나 오류를 수행하기 위해 텐서 곱으로 결합하는 게 편할 때가 많아요.
용어 측면에서 N qubit Pauli
연산이라고 할 때는 예시에서 보이는 것처럼 임의의 n개 Pauli 행렬의 텐서 곱을 의미해요.
전역 위상이 있을 때도 Pauli 연산이라는 용어를 쓰는 게 일반적이지만, 가능한 한 단순하게 유지하기 위해
저는 Pauli 연산이라는 용어를 단순히 Pauli 행렬의 텐서 곱을 의미하는 것으로 쓸 거예요. n qubit Pauli
연산의 가중치는 텐서 곱에서 비단위 Pauli 행렬의 수예요. 예를 들어, n겹 텐서
곱인 2x2 단위 행렬의 자기 자신과의 곱은 가중치 0의 Pauli 연산이고, 두 개의 Pauli X
행렬과 많은 단위 행렬들의 텐서 곱은 가중치가 2예요. 직관적으로 말하면, N
qubit Pauli 연산의 가중치는 그것이 비자명하게 작용하는 qubit의 수예요. 양자 오류 정정 코드는 일반적으로
특정 가중치까지의 Pauli 연산으로 나타낸 오류를 감지하고 정정할 수 있도록 설계돼요. Pauli 연산을
양자 gate에 의해 의도적으로 수행되는 연산으로 생각하는 등 다양한 방식으로 생각할 수 있고,
오류로도 생각할 수 있어요. 그리고 Pauli 연산이 측정을 설명할 수 있다는 것도 곧 보게 될 거예요. 때로는
대수적인 의미에서 특정 집합의 생성자로서 Pauli 연산을 생각하는 게 유용한데, 군론에 익숙하다면 알아볼 수도 있을 거예요.
군론에 익숙하지 않아도 괜찮아요. 이 강의에서는 정말 필수적인 건 아니에요.
하지만 양자 오류 정정을 더 깊이 공부하는 데 관심이 있다면, 기본적인
군론이 매우 도움이 될 거예요. 어쨌든, P1부터 PR까지가 n qubit Pauli 연산이라고 가정해봐요.
P1은 n qubit Pauli 연산이고, P2도 n qubit Pauli 연산이고, 이런 식이에요. P1부터 PR까지로 생성된 집합이라고 할 때
그 의미는 이 행렬들을 임의의 조합으로,
임의의 순서로 곱해서 얻을 수 있는 모든 행렬의 집합이에요. 각각을 원하는 만큼 여러 번 취할 수 있어요. 잠시 후에 몇 가지 예시를 볼 거예요.
하지만 먼저 이 집합을 나타내는 표기법을 언급할게요. P1부터 PR까지로 생성된 집합은
꺾쇠 괄호 안에 P1부터 PR을 쉼표로 구분한 거예요. 이 표기법이 내적 표기법과 헷갈릴 수 있어 보이지만
실제로는 그런 혼동이 잘 일어나지 않고, 이게 군론에서의 전통적인 표기법이에요.
X, Y, Z로 생성된 집합의 예시예요. 여기서 n은 1이에요. 텐서 곱이 없으니까요.
그리고 세 비단위 Pauli 행렬을 모두 생성자로 취하고 있어요. 이 세 행렬을 포함하는 곱을 형성해서
생성할 수 있는 행렬이 16개 있는데, 앞서 본 곱셈 규칙을 통해 이유를 알 수 있어요.
구체적으로, 물론 X, Y, Z뿐만 아니라 단위 행렬도 얻을 수 있고,
사실 이 네 행렬 각각에 i, 1, 또는 -i를 곱한 것도 얻을 수 있어요.
이 집합은 Pauli 군으로 널리 알려져 있어요. x와 z만으로 생성된 집합도 생각해볼 수 있는데,
이 경우 Pauli 군의 절반을 얻게 돼요.
그리고 적어도 지금으로서는 마지막 예시로, X 텐서 X와 Z 텐서 Z로 생성된 집합을 생각할 수 있어요. 그러니까 n이
2인 경우예요. 이번에는 원소가 딱 네 개인데, 그건 X 텐서 X와 Z 텐서 Z가
서로 교환하기 때문이에요. Pauli 행렬과 N qubit Pauli 연산은 더 일반적으로
오류든 의도적인 것이든 유니터리 연산을 설명하지만,
측정도 설명해요. 더 정확히 말하면, 세 비단위 Pauli 행렬만으로 시작해서 이것들 각각을
고유값과 고유벡터로 정의된 사영 측정과 연결 지을 수 있어요. 화면에
이 행렬들의 스펙트럼 분해가 있는데, 이걸 명확히 하는 데 도움이 될 거예요. 본질적으로 X
측정, Y 측정, 또는 Z 측정이라고 할 때, 이 행렬들의 고유 공간으로의 사영으로 정의된 사영 측정을 의미해요.
일반적으로 고유값을 대응하는 측정 결과로 생각해요. 예를 들어, X 측정은 qubit의 플러스
마이너스 기저에 대한 측정이에요. 또는 |+⟩⟨+|와
|−⟩⟨−|를 포함하는 집합으로 설명할 수도 있어요. 반면 Z 측정은 표준 기저
측정에 불과해요. 다만 말했듯이 고유값을 측정 결과와 동일시하는 경우도 있고, 그렇게 하면
결과가 0과 1이 아닌 플러스 1과 마이너스 1이 돼요. 사실 임의의 에르미트 행렬에 대해서도
비슷한 걸 할 수 있고, 이 상황에서 관측량이라는 용어가 일반적으로 사용돼요. Pauli
행렬과 n qubit Pauli 연산 일반에 대해, 위상 추정을 사용해서 이러한 측정을 비파괴적으로 수행할 수 있어요.
이 다이어그램이 명확한지 확인하기 위해 말하자면, 여기서 우리는 비파괴적으로 측정하고 있어요.
위쪽 qubit을 측정하는 거고, 아래쪽 qubit은 항상 플러스 상태로 초기화돼요. 즉, Hadamard를 영
상태에 적용한 거예요. 위상 추정이 그렇게 작동하거든요. 고유값이
이 경우 플러스 1과 마이너스 1뿐이니까, 제어 qubit이 하나만 필요해요. 이 다이어그램에서 아래쪽 qubit이에요.
그 이상은 낭비예요. 고유값이
플러스 1이거나 마이너스 1이고, 측정은 이미 이대로 완벽하니까요. 그런데 이 측정의 결과는,
즉 circuit에서의 표준 기저 측정 결과는, 플러스 1 고유값 결과에 대해 0이 될 거예요.
이건 X 관측량의 경우 플러스 상태에 대응하고, 마이너스 1 고유값에 대해서는 결과가 1이에요.
즉, 이 경우 마이너스 상태예요. 방금 말한 건 모두 자연스럽게 n qubit Pauli 연산으로 확장돼요.
관측량을 생각할 때는 고유벡터의 기저에 대해 측정하는 게 아니라 고유값을 측정한다는 점을 염두에 두어야 해요.
예를 들어, 2
qubit Pauli 연산 Z 텐서 Z를 생각해봐요. 다시 한번, 고유값은 플러스 1과 마이너스 1 두 개예요. 그래서
측정은 두 개의 사영으로 설명돼요. 특히, 이 관측량과 연결 지은 측정은
두 qubit 모두를 Z 측정, 즉 표준 기저 측정으로 측정하는 것과 다르다는 점에 주목하세요. 오히려 그건 두 개의
결과를 가진 사영 측정인데, 사영이 두 개의 고유값 플러스 1과 마이너스 1 각각에 대응하는 모든 고유벡터가 생성하는
공간으로 이루어져요. 이것을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은, 텐서 곱의 고유값이
텐서 곱을 취하는 개별 행렬들의 고유값의 곱이라는 거예요. 예를 들어,
-1 * -1이 +1 * +1과 같으니까, 이 측정은
|00⟩과 |11⟩을 구별하지 못해요. 예를 들어 |Φ+⟩ Bell 상태를 이 관측량으로 설명된 측정으로 측정한다면,
플러스 1 고유값에 대응하는 결과를 얻을 게 확실해요.
그리고 상태는 두 qubit에 표준 기저 측정을 수행했을 때처럼 |00⟩이나 |11⟩으로 붕괴하는 게 아니라 변하지 않아요.
그래서 Z 텐서 Z 측정은
Z 측정 두 개를 독립적으로 수행하는 것과 다르지만, 위상 추정을 사용해서 이런 측정을 수행할 수 있어요.
이전과 정확히 같은 방식으로, 단일 제어 qubit을 사용해서요. circuit 다이어그램에 보이는 것처럼요.
이건 Z 텐서 Z 대신 임의의 n qubit Pauli 연산으로 일반화돼요. Z Pauli 행렬만 있을 때는,
이런 식으로 circuit을 단순화할 수 있는데, 이게 측정을 정의하는 사영에서도 명확히 보여주는 건
두 qubit에 Z 텐서 Z 측정을 수행하는 게 표준 기저로 생각할 때 그들의 패리티를 측정하는 것과 동일하다는 거예요.
이건 임의의 수의 Pauli Z 행렬의 텐서 곱으로 일반화돼요.
다음으로 3비트 반복 코드를 다시 살펴볼게요. 이번엔 Pauli 연산의 관점에서요.
이게 안정자 코드의 첫 번째이자 상당히 간단한 예시가 될 거예요. 이걸 어떻게 일반화하는지
곧 논의할 거지만, 이 간단한 경우에서 어떻게 작동하는지 먼저 보는 게 도움이 돼요. 먼저
3비트 반복 코드를 qubit에 적용할 때, 주어진 qubit 상태 α|0⟩ + β|1⟩을 α|000⟩ + β|111⟩로 인코딩한다는 걸 떠올려봐요.
이 세 qubit 인코딩을 편의상 Ψ라고 부를게요. 정의상 Ψ는 유효한 세 qubit
qubit 상태의 인코딩이에요. 하지만 이걸 확인하려면, 다음 두 방정식이 참인지 확인하는 것으로 충분해요.
첫 번째 방정식은 Ψ의 가장 왼쪽 두 qubit에 Z 연산을 적용해도 Ψ에 아무것도 하지 않는다고 해요. 즉, Ψ가
Z 텐서 Z 텐서 단위 행렬, 줄여서 ZZ단위의 고유벡터이고 고유값이 1이라는 거예요. 두 번째
방정식도 비슷한데, Z 연산이 가장 오른쪽 두 qubit에 적용돼요. 아이디어는 Ψ를
표준 기저 상태의 선형 결합으로 생각하면, 첫 번째 방정식은 가장 왼쪽 두 비트가 짝수 패리티를 갖는, 즉 동일한 표준 기저 상태에만 0이 아닌 계수를 가질 수 있다는 걸 의미해요.
두 번째 방정식은 가장 오른쪽 두 비트가 짝수 패리티를 갖는 표준 기저 상태에만 0이 아닌
계수를 가질 수 있다는 걸 의미해요. 이걸 생각하는 또 다른 방법은
이 두 Pauli 연산을 관측량으로 보는 거예요. 방금 전에 언급한 단순화된 circuit으로 이 두 관측량을 측정한다면,
Ψ가 두 관측량 모두의 고유벡터이고 고유값이 1이니까, 플러스 1 고유값에 대응하는 측정 결과를 얻을 게 확실해요.
하지만 이 결합된 단순화 버전은
Ψ가 두 관측량 모두의 고유벡터이고 고유값이 1이기 때문이에요.
관측량을 독립적으로 측정하는 combined circuit은 다름 아닌 3비트 반복 코드의 패리티 검사 circuit이에요.
그래서 두 방정식을 합치면 패리티 검사 circuit이 0 0을 출력하는 것과 동일하다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
이건 오류가 감지되지 않았음을 나타내는 신드롬이에요. 세 qubit Pauli 연산
ZZ단위와 단위ZZ는 이 코드의 안정자 생성자라고 불려요. 코드의 안정자는
안정자 생성자로 생성된 집합이에요. 이 집합, 즉 안정자는 이 코드와 연결된 근본적으로 중요한 수학적
개체예요. 강의가 계속되면서 그것이 하는 역할에 대해 더 논의할 거예요. 지금은
생성자를 다른 방식으로 선택할 수도 있었다는 점만 말할게요. 예를 들어, 우리가 선택한 생성자 중 하나 대신 Z단위Z를 선택할 수도 있었는데,
코드와 안정자는 완전히 동일했을 거예요. 다음으로 3비트 반복 코드에서의 비트 플립 감지를 살펴볼게요.
관련된 Pauli 연산들, 즉 안정자 생성자와 오류 자체 사이의
상호작용과 관계에 초점을 맞춰서요. 3비트 반복 코드로 qubit을 인코딩했고 가장 왼쪽 qubit에 비트 플립 오류가 발생했다고 가정해봐요.
이건 상태 Ψ를 가장 왼쪽 qubit에 대한 X 연산 또는 X 오류의 작용에 따라 변환시켜요.
이미 알고 있듯이, 3비트 반복 코드의 패리티 검사를 수행해서 이 오류를 감지할 수 있어요. 또는 동등하게
안정자 생성자를 관측량으로 처리해서 인코딩을 비파괴적으로 측정할 수 있어요. 첫 번째
안정자 생성자부터 시작해서 어떤 일이 일어나는지 보죠. 상태가 X 오류의 영향을 받았고,
관측량으로서 안정자 생성자의 측정이 이 오류에 의해 어떻게 영향받는지 이해하고 싶어요.
x와 z는 반교환하는 반면, 모든 것은 단위 행렬과 교환해요. 그러므로 ZZ단위는 X단위단위와 반교환해요.
즉, 순서가 바뀔 때 마이너스 부호가 나와요. 또한 ZZ단위는 Ψ에 아무것도 하지 않는다는 것도 알고 있어요.
Ψ가 유효한 qubit 인코딩이고, 유효한 인코딩은 항상 두 안정자 생성자 모두의 플러스 1 고유벡터이거든요.
그러면 -X단위단위를 Ψ에 적용한 게 남아요. 따라서 X단위단위를 Ψ에 적용한 건
고유값이 -1인 ZZ단위의 고유벡터예요. 두 번째 안정자 생성자로도 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요.
하지만 이번엔 오류가 안정자 생성자와 교환하고, 따라서 손상된 상태는 다시 안정자 생성자의 고유벡터가 되지만
이번엔 고유값이 +1이에요. 그러므로 손상된 상태는 두 안정자 생성자 모두의 고유벡터이고,
고유값이 +1인지 -1인지는 오류가 각 안정자 생성자와 교환하는지 반교환하는지에 의해 결정돼요.
첫 번째 경우 오류와 안정자 생성자는 반교환하고, 두 번째 경우는 교환해요. 두 Pauli 연산은 항상
교환하거나 반교환하니까, 항상 둘 중 하나예요. 한편, 실제 상태 Ψ는 여기서
안정자 생성자가 이 상태에 자명하게 작용한다는 사실 외에는 중요한 역할을 하지 않아요. 그래서 오류
감지를 생각할 때는 특정 인코딩 상태에 신경 쓸 필요가 없어요. 오류가 각 안정자 생성자와 교환하는지 반교환하는지만
중요해요. 그러니 안정자 생성자마다 행 하나, 오류마다 열 하나인 표를 만들어봐요.
여기서는 오류 없음을 나타내는 단위 행렬의 세 번 텐서 곱뿐만 아니라 단일 비트 플립에 해당하는 오류만 포함했어요.
원한다면 다른 오류에 대한 열을 더 추가할 수 있지만, 지금은 이 오류들에만 집중할 거예요. 표의 항목은
오류와 안정자 생성자가 교환하는지 반교환하는지에 따라 +1 또는 -1이에요. 표의 각 오류에 대해
해당 열을 보면 그 오류가 주어진 인코딩을 각 안정자 생성자의 +1 또는 -1 고유벡터로 어떻게 변환하는지 알 수 있어요.
이 열들은 패리티 검사에서 얻는 신드롬에 정확히 대응해요. 패리티 검사는 관측량으로서의
안정자 생성자의 비파괴적 측정과 동일해요. 물론
이 표의 항목은 각각 0과 1이 아닌 +1과 -1이에요. 원한다면 신드롬을 +1과 -1의 열이 아닌
대응하는 이진 문자열로 생각할 수 있지만, 직접적인 대응 관계가 있어요.
신드롬과 고유값의 연결을 더 명확하게 하기 위해,
이 +1과 -1의 벡터들을 이전처럼 신드롬이라고 부를 거예요. 신드롬은
어떤 오류가 발생했는지에 대해 뭔가를 알려줘요. 특히 이 네 가지 가능한 오류 중 하나가
발생했다는 걸 안다면, 신드롬은 어떤 오류인지 알려주고, 원하면 오류를 다시 적용해서 수정할 수 있어요.
다음으로 신드롬에 대해 조금 더 얘기할게요. 특히 대수적 측면을 더 자세히 살펴볼 거예요.
인코딩은 세 qubit 상태이므로 8차원 복소 벡터 공간의 단위 벡터예요. 네 가지 가능한 신드롬이 하는 일은
이 8차원 공간을 네 개의 2차원 부분 공간으로 나누는 거예요. 즉, 이 부분 공간 중 하나의 벡터는 항상 같은 신드롬을 줘요.
더 자세하게는, 이 다이어그램이 8차원 공간이 어떻게 나뉘는지 보여줘요.
각 안정자 생성자는 공간을 동일한 차원의 두 부분 공간, 즉 +1 고유벡터 공간과
-1 고유벡터 공간으로 나눠요. 예를 들어, ZZ단위의 +1 벡터는 가장 왼쪽 두 비트가 짝수 패리티를 갖는
표준 기저 상태의 선형 결합이고, -1 고유벡터는 가장 왼쪽 두 비트가 홀수 패리티를 갖는
표준 기저 상태의 선형 결합이에요. 다른 안정자 생성자도 상황이 비슷한데,
가장 왼쪽 두 비트 대신 가장 오른쪽 두 비트예요. 이 경우 네 부분 공간은
이 코드가 매우 단순하기 때문에 쉽게 설명할 수 있어요. 특히,
신드롬 (+1, +1)에 대응하는 부분 공간은 |000⟩과 |111⟩이 생성하는 공간인데,
이게 유효한 인코딩의 공간이고 코드 공간이라고 불려요. 일반적으로 공간들은 대응하는 사각형에 표시된 표준 기저 상태로 생성되지만,
신드롬을 보는 것이 항상 이렇게 명확하거나 쉽지는 않을 수도 있어요. 신드롬은 또한
발생할 수 있는 가능한 Pauli 오류를 나타내는 모든 세 qubit Pauli 연산을 네 개의 동일한 크기의 집합으로 분할해요.
오류가 일으킬 신드롬에 따라서요. 예를 들어, 두 안정자 생성자 모두와 교환하는 Pauli 연산은
신드롬 (+1, +1)을 만들어요. 64개의 가능한 세
qubit Pauli 연산 중에서 화면에 언급된 세 개를 포함해 이 범주에 정확히 16개가 있어요.
다른 세 신드롬도 마찬가지예요.
어떤 신드롬이 오류를 일으키느냐에 따라서요. 예를 들어, 두 안정자 생성자 모두와 교환하는 Pauli 연산은
신드롬 (+1, +1)을 만들어요. 64개의 가능한 세
qubit Pauli 연산 중에서 화면에 언급된 세 개를 포함해 이 범주에 정확히 16개가 있고, 다른 세 범주도 마찬가지예요.
그건 명확하지 않지만 사실이에요. 신드롬이 인코딩이 존재하는 상태 공간과 공간의 모든 가능한 Pauli 오류 모두를
동일한 크기의 부분들로 분할한다는 이 기본 속성은
안정자 코드 일반에서도 사실인데, 곧 정확히 정의할 거예요. 이 시점에서는 대부분 여담이지만,
두 안정자 생성자 모두와 교환하는 Pauli 연산, 즉 동등하게
신드롬 (+1, +1)을 만들지만 안정자의 원소에 비례하지 않는 Pauli 연산은 인코딩한 논리 qubit에서의
단일 qubit Pauli 연산처럼 작동한다는 점을 언급할 가치가 있어요. 예를 들어, XXX는
두 안정자 생성자 모두와 교환하지만 안정자의 어떤 원소에도 비례하지 않아요. 잠시 이 코드를 생각해보면
이 연산이 인코딩에 미치는 효과가 인코딩된 논리 qubit에 대한 X gate와 동일하다는 게 명확해요.
다시 말하지만, 이건 모든 안정자 코드로 일반화돼요. 이제 안정자 코드를 일반적으로 정의할 시간이에요.
작동 방식은 3비트 반복 코드에서 방금 논의한 것과 완전히 유사하게 하는 건데,
다른 안정자 생성자를 선택한다는 점이 달라요. 이 설명에서는 P1부터
PR까지라고 부를게요. 이 안정자 생성자들은 모두 n qubit Pauli 연산이어야 해요.
여기서 n은 인코딩에 사용되는 qubit의 수예요. 아무 안정자 생성자 집합이나 선택할 수 있는 건 아니에요.
몇 가지 기본 조건을 만족해야 해요. 첫째, 안정자 생성자들은 모두 서로 교환해야 해요.
3비트 반복 코드의 경우에는 이걸 언급하지 않았지만, ZZ단위와 단위ZZ가
실제로 교환한다는 건 쉽게 확인할 수 있어요. Z는 자기 자신과 교환하고, 모든 것은 단위 행렬과 교환하거든요.
X와 Z 모두 안정자 생성자에 나타나는 코드를 포함해 더 복잡한 안정자 생성자를 가진 안정자 코드의 경우에는
이게 확인해야 할 중요한 조건이에요. 이 조건이 필요한 이유를 생각하는 한 가지 방법은,
안정자 생성자를 관측량으로 처리할 건데, 모두 교환하도록 요구함으로써
이 측정을 수행하는 순서가 중요하지 않도록 보장한다는 거예요.
둘째, 안정자 생성자들은 소위 최소 생성 집합을 구성해야 해요. 즉, 그 중 하나라도 제거하면 더 작은 안정자를 얻게 된다는 거예요.
이걸 수학적으로 표현하는 한 가지 방법이 화면에 나와 있어요.
엄밀히 말하면, 이 조건은 안정자 코드가 작동하는 방식의 운영적 의미에서는 실제로 필수적인 건 아니에요.
다음 강의에서 보겠지만, 때로는 비최소 생성 집합을 생각하는 것도 의미가 있어요. 하지만
안정자 코드를 분석하고 그 속성을 설명하기 위해 이 조건이 있다고 가정할 거예요.
기본적으로 이 조건은 신드롬을 얻기 위해 측정하는 각 관측량이 가능한 오류에 대한 정보를 추가하고
다른 안정자 생성자로부터 쉽게 추론할 수 있는 결과를 주는 중복이 아니라는 걸 보장해요.
그리고 마지막으로, 적어도 하나의 비영 벡터가 모든 안정자 생성자에 의해 고정되어야 해요.
이건 n qubit에서의 -1 곱하기 단위 행렬이 안정자에 포함되지 않아야 한다는 것과 동일해요.
명확하지 않을 수 있지만, 요점은 모두 서로 교환하는 n qubit Pauli 연산의 최소 생성 집합을 선택할 수 있지만
그 모두의 +1 고유벡터인 벡터가 동시에 존재하지 않을 수도 있다는 거예요.
유효한 인코딩이 없는 코드는 흥미롭지 않으니까, 이 가능성을 신경 쓰고 싶지 않아요.
그게 안정자 코드에서 안정자 생성자에 대한 요건이에요. 이 조건을 만족하는 생성자 집합이 있다면
유효한 안정자 코드가 있고, 그 속성을 살펴볼 수 있어요. 흥미롭거나 그렇지 않게 만드는 다양한 속성을 가진
안정자 코드가 많이 있지만, 3비트 반복 코드에서 이미 관찰한 것들을 떠올리게 하는 특정 기본 속성을
모두 만족해요. 잠시 후 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼 거예요. 하지만 그 전에, 안정자 코드의 코드 공간이라고 할 때
n qubit 상태 공간의 부분 공간을 의미한다는 점을 언급할게요. 이 부분 공간은 모든 안정자 생성자 하나하나의
+1 고유벡터인 모든 벡터를 포함해요.
이게 유효한 인코딩이 존재하는 n qubit 상태 공간의 부분 공간이에요. 강의가 계속되면서 이 부분 공간에 대해 더 얘기할 거예요.
이제 안정자 코드의 몇 가지 예시를 살펴봐요.
이미 논의한 예시인 일반 3비트 반복 코드예요. 이전 강의에서 본 수정된 버전의 코드도
안정자 코드로 표현할 수 있어요. 비트 플립 대신 위상 플립을 감지할 수 있는데, 여기에 나온 것처럼요.
이번엔 안정자 생성자가 ZZ 관측량이 아닌 XX 관측량을 측정해요. 이건 기본적으로
표준 기저가 아닌 플러스 마이너스 기저에서의 패리티 검사예요. 두 경우 모두
유효한 안정자 코드임을 바로 알 수 있어요. 안정자 생성자들이 교환하고, 최소 생성 집합이며,
이미 알고 있듯이 코드 공간이 비자명하기 때문이에요. 하지만 -1 곱하기 단위 행렬을 생성할 수 없다는 것도
꽤 명확하게 볼 수 있어요. 그리고 여기 9 qubit Shore 코드가 있는데, 이것도 안정자 코드예요.
이 경우 안정자 생성자로 표현돼요. 기본적으로 3비트
반복 코드의 세 복사본이 있어요. 세 qubit 블록 각각에 대해 하나씩이요. 마지막 두 안정자 생성자도 있는데,
이 코드에서 위상 플립을 감지하기 위한 이전 강의의 circuit과 유사한 형태예요.
이 마지막 두 안정자 생성자를 생각하는 또 다른 방법은, 위상 플립에 대해 3비트 반복 코드에서 가지는 것과
정확히 같은 형태인데, x 대신 XXX를 대입한다는 거예요. 그 이유는
XXX가 3비트 반복 코드로 인코딩된 논리 qubit에서의 X 연산에 대응하기 때문이에요. 하지만
이건 여담이고 지금 당장 걱정할 건 아니에요. 명확하지 않을 경우를 대비해, 다음으로 더 많은 예시를 살펴볼게요.
하지만 그 전에, 안정자 코드를 설명할 때 텐서 곱 기호를 생략하는 경우가 많다는 점을 언급할게요. 읽기 쉬워지는 경향이 있거든요.
그래서 이 코드들은 텐서 곱 기호 없이 이렇게 보여요.
물론 이것들은 일반 행렬 곱이 아닌 텐서 곱이에요. 예를 들어, 텐서 곱 기호를 생략해서
덜 복잡하고 패턴이 더 명확하게 보이도록 하는 거예요. 여기 또 다른 예시가 있어요.
7 qubit Steane 코드라고 불리는데, 꽤 주목할 만한 특징이 있어요. 단원의 나머지 강의에서
이걸 가끔 다시 보게 될 거예요. 하지만 지금은 유효한 안정자 코드인지 확인하는 것으로 충분해요.
특히, 처음 세 안정자 생성자는 Z가 자기 자신과 교환하기 때문에 서로 명확히 교환해요.
단위 행렬은 모든 것과 교환하고, 마지막 세 개도 상황이 비슷해요. 따라서 Z 안정자 생성자 하나와 X 안정자 생성자 하나를 취하면
서로 교환하는지 확인해야 해요.
아홉 가지 가능한 쌍을 살펴보는 건 충분히 쉬운데, 이 모든 경우에서 항상
같은 위치에서 X와 Z가 짝수 번 매칭된다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 그래서 두 생성자는
XX와 ZZ가 교환하는 것처럼 교환해요. 최소 생성 집합이고 비자명한 코드 공간을 가지지만,
이 영상에서는 그걸 논증하지 않고, 원한다면 스스로 생각해볼 거리로 남겨둘게요. 7 qubit Steane 코드는
단일 qubit을 인코딩하고 한 qubit에서의 임의적인 오류 정정을 허용한다는 점에서 9 qubit Shore 코드와 비슷해요. 하지만
아홉 개가 아닌 일곱 개의 qubit만 필요해요. 그게 qubit을 인코딩하고
단일 qubit에서의 임의적인 오류를 정정하기 위한 오류 정정 코드에 필요한 가장 적은 qubit 수는 아니에요.
5 qubit 코드라고 불리는 안정자 코드가 있는데, 단일 qubit을 인코딩하고 임의의 단일 qubit 오류를 정정할 수 있어요.
그리고 5가 이게 가능한 가장 작은 qubit 수예요. 또 다른 안정자 코드 예시가 있는데,
엄밀히 말하면 코드 공간이 1차원이라는 의미에서 정말 코드라고 하기 어렵긴 해요.
특히, 이 코드의 코드 공간은 ebit, 즉 |Φ+⟩ Bell
상태가 생성하는 공간이에요. 이 코드로는 실제로 qubit을 인코딩할 수 없지만, 코드 공간이 1차원인 유효한 안정자 코드예요.
GHZ 상태에 대해서도 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요.
그게 안정자 코드의 몇 가지 예시예요. 다음 강의에서 무한히 많은 예시를 더 보게 될 거예요.
안정자 코드가 주어졌을 때 자연스럽게 물어볼 수 있는 질문이 있어요.
아마도 가장 먼저 떠오르는 질문은 몇 개의 qubit을 인코딩하는지예요. 그 질문은 매우 간단한
답이 있어요. 설명하기 위해 고려하는 안정자 코드에 대해 정확하게 말해봐요. R개의 n qubit
안정자 생성자 P1부터 PR이 있고, 앞서 언급한 세 가지 요건, 즉
안정자 생성자들이 모두 서로 교환하고, 생성자 중 하나를 제거하면 같은 안정자를 얻지 못하도록 최소 생성 집합이며,
코드 공간에 적어도 하나의 비영 벡터가 있다는 조건을 만족해요.
화면에 나온 정리가 나타내듯이, 안정자 코드의 코드 공간은
차원이 2^(n-r)이어야 해요. 다시 말하면, 이 코드를 사용해서 n
빼기 r개의 qubit을 인코딩할 수 있어요. 직관적으로 말하면, 인코딩에 n개의 qubit이 있고 각
안정자 생성자가 인코딩할 수 있는 qubit 수 측면에서 qubit 하나를 빼는 거예요.
이 정리는 증명하기 그리 어렵지 않고, 잠시 후에 증명을 보여드릴게요. 먼저
몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 일반 3비트 반복 코드부터 시작하면, 인코딩에 세 qubit이 있으니
n이 3이고, R = 2개의 안정자 생성자가 있어요. 따라서 이 코드로 하나의
qubit을 인코딩할 수 있어요. 이건 어떤 오류가 감지되거나 정정될 수 있는지와는 무관해요.
그건 별개의 문제예요. 이건 코드 공간의 차원에 대한 진술이에요.
또 다른 예시로 5 qubit 코드를 생각해봐요. 여기서 qubit이 다섯 개 있고 안정자 생성자가 네 개 있어요.
다시 한번 코드 공간의 차원이 2인데, 이 코드로 하나의 qubit을 인코딩할 수 있다는 의미예요.
그리고 지금으로서는 또 다른 예시로, ebit 안정자 코드에서 qubit이 두 개 있고 안정자 생성자가 두 개 있어요.
따라서 코드 공간은 1차원이고, 앞서 언급했듯이 |Φ+⟩ Bell 상태가 생성하는 공간이에요.
계속 진행하면서 하나 이상의 qubit을 인코딩할 수 있는 코드를 포함한 더 많은 예시를 보게 될 거예요. 하지만 지금은
정리를 어떻게 증명하는지 살펴봐요. 먼저 안정자 생성자들이 교환하고 최소 생성 집합을 이루며
모든 Pauli 연산이 그 자신의 역이기 때문에, 안정자의 모든 원소는
각 안정자 생성자 PK를 AK 거듭제곱한 곱으로 고유하게 표현될 수 있다는 걸 관찰해야 해요.
각 AK는 0 또는 1이고, 결과를 곱해요.
다시 말하면, 안정자 생성자의 어떤 부분 집합을 곱해서 안정자의 모든 원소를 얻을 수 있고,
다른 부분 집합으로 같은 안정자 원소를 얻지는 않아요. 이것이 함의하는 한 가지는,
n qubit 단위 연산을 이런 방식으로 표현하는 유일한 방법은 모든 거듭제곱을 0으로 취하는 거라는 거예요.
다음으로, K가 1에서 R까지 각 K에 대해 πK를 PK의 +1 고유 공간으로의 사영이라고 정의해봐요. 이 사영에 대한
간단한 공식이 있어요. PK와 n qubit 단위 행렬을 평균하면 되는데, 이건 +1 고유값은 그대로 두고
-1 고유값을 모두 0으로 이동시켜요.
코드 공간은 모든 안정자 생성자의 +1 고유벡터인 모든 벡터의 집합으로 정의돼요.
안정자 생성자들이 교환하기 때문에 사영들도 교환해야 하고, 그러면
이 사영들의 곱도 사영이에요. 특히, 그건 개별 사영들이 사영하는 부분 공간들의
교집합으로의 사영이에요. 다시 말하면, 코드 공간으로의 사영이에요. 이 곱을 펼치면 안정자의 모든 원소에 대한
평균이 나와요. 마지막으로, 어떤 부분 공간의 차원이 그 부분 공간으로의
사영의 트레이스와 같으니까, 코드 공간의 차원은 안정자 원소들에 대한 트레이스의 평균이에요.
하지만 n qubit 단위 연산을 제외하면 안정자의 모든 원소는
트레이스가 0이어야 해요. 세 비단위 Pauli 행렬이 모두 트레이스가 0이거든요. n qubit 단위 연산의 트레이스는
2^n이고, 따라서 코드 공간의 차원은 2^(n-r)이에요. 이걸로 정리가 증명돼요.
다음으로 안정자 코드를 사용해서 qubit을 어떻게 인코딩할 수 있는지에 대해 조금 얘기할게요. 그러려면 먼저
Clifford 연산을 소개해야 해요. Clifford 연산은 임의의 수의
qubit에 대한 유니터리 연산인데, Hadamard gate, S gate,
그리고 controlled-NOT gate라는 제한된 게이트 집합으로 quantum circuit을 구현할 수 있어요. T gate는 포함되지 않고, Toffoli gate나 Fredkin
gate도 포함되지 않는다는 점에 주목하세요. 이 gate들이 목록에 포함되지 않을 뿐만 아니라, 실제로 그 gate들을
Clifford 연산으로 구현하는 건 불가능해요.
여기 나열된 것들로는요. 그러니까 Clifford 연산이 아니에요. 반면에 Pauli 연산은
Clifford 연산이고, 특히 Hadamard gate와 S gate의 시퀀스로 구현할 수 있어요.
Clifford 연산을 정의하는 간단한 방법이지만, 왜 이렇게 정의하는지나 이 특정 gate 모음이 뭐가 특별한지는 설명하지 않아요.
Clifford 연산이 이렇게 정의되는 진짜 이유가 있어요.
전역 위상을 제외하고, n qubit Clifford 연산은 정확히 켤레(conjugation)에 의해 Pauli 연산을 항상 Pauli 연산으로 변환하는 유니터리
연산이에요. 더 정확히 말하면, n 비트 유니터리 연산 U는 전역 위상 인자를 제외하고 모든 n qubit Pauli
연산을 U로 켤레하면 +1 또는 -1 곱하기 어떤 n qubit Pauli 연산을 줄 때만, 그리고 그럴 때만 Clifford 연산이에요.
이 속성이 Hadamard gate, S
gate, CNOT gate에서 참이라는 건 쉽게 확인할 수 있어요. 그러므로 이 gate들로 구성된 circuit에 대해서도 반드시 성립해요. 더 어렵게 증명해야 하는 건
반대 방향이에요. 즉, 이 속성을 만족하는 특정 n 비트 유니터리 연산 U가 주어지면
Hadamard, S, CNOT gate만을 사용해서 전역 위상을 제외하고 구현할 수 있어야 해요.
그 함의의 증명을 살펴보지는 않겠지만, 사실이에요. 관심 있으면 찾아볼 수 있어요.
Clifford 연산은 양자 계산에 있어 보편적이지 않아요. 즉, Hadamard, S, CNOT gate만으로
임의적인 양자 계산을 실행할 수 없어요. 사실 주어진 n 값에 대해 n qubit Clifford 연산의 수는 유한해요.
그래서 이산 연산 집합이에요. 보편적인 양자 gate 집합과는 달리,
임의의 유니터리 연산을 원하는 수준의 정확도로 근사할 수 없어요.
사실, 표준 기저 상태에 대한 Clifford 연산 수행 후 표준 기저 측정은
고전 알고리즘의 범위를 넘어서는 계산을 허용할 수 없어요. 이 형태의 계산을 효율적으로 고전적으로 시뮬레이션할 수 있거든요.
이 사실은 Gottesman-Knill 정리로 알려져 있고, 그 정리의 표준 증명은 어떤 의미에서
안정자 형식론에 기반해요. 특히 작동 방식은, Clifford 연산이 켤레에 의해 Pauli 연산을 어떻게 변환하는지 추적할 수 있고,
이건 효율적으로 할 수 있어요. 그리고 거기서 계산이 qubit에 무엇을 하는지 추론할 수 있어요.
그러면 이게 안정자 코드와 무슨 관련이 있을까요? 안정자 코드는
특정 차원의 코드 공간을 제공하고, 우리는 그 코드 공간을 원하는 방식으로 자유롭게 사용할 수 있어요.
그러므로 특정 방식으로 qubit을 그 공간에 인코딩하도록 강제하는 건 없지만, Clifford 연산을 인코더로 사용해서
항상 인코딩을 수행하는 게 가능할 거예요. Clifford 연산이 임의적인 유니터리
연산에 비해 상대적으로 단순하기 때문에 좋아요. Gottesman-Knill 정리 증명과 유사한 방식으로 구현을 최적화하는 방법이 있고,
결과적으로 구현을 위한 circuit은 크게 클 필요가 없어요.
특히, Clifford 연산의 실제 속성이기 때문에 이차보다 약간 적은 수의 gate를 필요로 하는 Clifford 연산을 사용해서 항상 인코딩을 수행할 수 있어요.
따라서 요점은 주어진 안정자 코드에 대해 항상 그 코드를 사용해서 qubit을 효율적으로 인코딩하는 게 가능하고,
Clifford 연산을 이해하는 데 유용한 수학적 도구가 이 과정에 도움이 될 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 7 qubit Steane 코드의 인코더가 있어요. Clifford 연산인데, 알고 보면
이건 S gate도 필요하지 않아요. 일반 안정자 코드에서 오류 감지는 다음과 같이 작동해요.
이전처럼 n qubit 안정자 생성자 P1부터 PR이 있다고 가정할게요. E를 인코딩에서의 가상의 오류를 나타내는 n qubit Pauli
연산이라고 해요. 순전히 Pauli
연산만 오류로 고려하는데, 오류의 이산화가 9 qubit Shore 코드에서처럼 임의의 안정자 코드에서도 같은 방식으로 작동하기 때문이에요.
오류를 확인하는 방법은 각 안정자 생성자를 관측량으로 측정하는 거예요.
R개의 안정자 생성자가 있으니, R개의 결과가 있어요. 각각은 +1 또는 -1이거나,
+1을 0으로, -1을 1로 연결 짓는다면 이진 값이에요. 이 R개의 결과를 합치면
3비트 반복 코드에서처럼 신드롬을 이뤄요. R이 2와 같았던 것처럼요.
일반적으로 오류 e에 대해 감지 측면에서 세 가지 가능한 경우가 있어요.
첫째, e가 안정자에 있을 수 있어요. 즉, 안정자 생성자로부터 E를 생성하는 게 가능하거나,
좀 더 일반적으로 e가 전역 위상을 제외하고 안정자 원소와 동일할 수 있어요.
이 경우 e는 전역 위상을 주입할 수 있다는 것 외에는 코드 공간에 아무 효과도 없기 때문에 실제로 오류가 아니에요.
전역 위상은 아무 효과가 없으니까요. 이런 오류는 전혀 걱정할 필요 없어요. 비자명한 작용이 있다면
코드 공간 외부에서 발생하니까, 그건 우리와 무관해요. 훨씬 더 우려스러운 건
e가 전역 위상을 제외하고도 안정자에 없지만,
그럼에도 모든 안정자 생성자와 교환하는 가능성이에요. 오류와 안정자 생성자의 반교환이
신드롬 어딘가에 -1을 나타나게 하는 거라는 걸 기억하세요.
하지만 이 경우는 그렇지 않아요. 그러므로 이건 코드 공간의 벡터를 실제로 비자명한 방식으로 변경하는 오류이고,
그렇지 않다면 안정자 원소에 비례할 테니까 알고 있어요. 하지만 코드에 의해
감지되지 않아요. 그게 나쁜 경우예요. 잠재적으로 우리가 인코딩한 양자 정보를 변경하는 오류가 있지만
코드는 이 사실을 모르고 있어요. 예를 들어, 3비트
반복 코드에서 XXX가 이 범주에 해당해요. 마지막 가능성은 e가
적어도 하나의 안정자 생성자와 반교환하는 거예요. 이는 코드가 이 오류를 감지한다는 의미예요.
신드롬에 적어도 하나의 -1이 있어서 뭔가 잘못됐다는 걸 나타내고, 이 오류를 어떻게든 수정하려고 할 거거든요.
그게 가능성들이에요. 용어 측면에서,
안정자 코드의 거리라고 할 때 두 번째 범주에 해당하는 Pauli 연산의 최소 가중치를 의미해요.
즉, 코드 공간을 비자명한 방식으로 변경하지만 코드가 감지하지 못하는 거예요.
안정자 코드를 [[n, m, d]] 안정자 코드라고 할 때,
화면에 보이는 이중 대괄호를 사용해서요. 그 의미는 인코딩이 n qubit 길이이고,
m개의 qubit을 인코딩하며, 거리가 d라는 거예요.
코드는 M qubit을 인코딩할 수 있으니 코드 공간의 차원이 2^m이고, 거리는 D예요. 따라서 오류가 감지되지 않고
인코딩된 qubit의 논리 상태를 변경하려면 가중치가 D 이상이어야 해요.
이제 7 qubit Steane 코드를 예시로 살펴보고 그 거리가 무엇인지 파악해볼게요.
이 코드의 안정자 생성자들이 있고, 거리는 모든 안정자 생성자와 교환하지만
안정자에 있지 않고, 안정자 원소에 비례하지도 않는 n qubit Pauli 연산의 최소 가중치라는 걸 떠올리세요.
우리가 파악할 건 이 코드의 거리가
3이라는 거예요. 파악하는 방법은 먼저 가중치가 최대 2인 Pauli 연산을 고려하는 거예요.
모든 여섯 안정자 생성자와 교환할 수 있는 유일한 방법은 안정자의 원소인 단위 행렬이라는 걸 결론내릴 거예요.
비단위 Pauli 행렬이 이 연산을 형성하고 P와 Q라고 부를 텐데, 가장 왼쪽 두 위치에 나타난다고 가정해봐요.
이건 하나의 경우이고, 비단위 Pauli 행렬의 다른 가능한 위치도 모두 고려해야 해요.
하지만 논증은 모든 가능한 위치에서 기본적으로 동일해요. 가정상 이 연산은 모든 여섯
안정자 생성자와 교환해요. 특히 이 것과 교환하고, 이 것과도 교환해요.
Q는 이 두 생성자 모두에서 단위 행렬과 매치되는데, 그래서 이 두 개를 선택한 거예요.
이 오류의 가장 오른쪽 다섯 위치에 단위 행렬이 있어요. 그러므로 P는 x와 z 모두와 교환해야 해요.
그렇지 않으면 이 오류가 두 생성자 중 하나와 반교환하게 되거든요. 하지만 x와 z 모두와 교환하는 유일한 Pauli 행렬은
단위 행렬이에요. 따라서 P는 단위 행렬이어야 해요. 이제 그걸 알면,
왼쪽에서 두 번째 위치에 X와 Z가 있는 안정자 생성자 두 개를 더 선택할 수 있어요.
Q에 대해서도 비슷한 결론을 내릴 수 있어요. 따라서 이 코드에서 가중치 최대 2인 오류가 감지되지 않을 방법이 없어요.
안정자에 있는 단위 연산인 경우 외에는요. 그건 실제로 오류가 아니에요.
반면에, 이 여섯 안정자 생성자 모두와 교환하지만 안정자 원소에 비례하지 않는 가중치 3의 Pauli 연산이 있어요.
두 가지 예시가 있어요. 따라서 이 코드의 거리가 3이라는 결론을 내렸어요.
이 강의에서 마지막으로 논의할 건 안정자 코드의 오류 정정이에요.
보통처럼 코드가 n 비트 안정자 생성자
P1부터 PR로 명세된다고 가정할게요. 먼저 발생할 수 있는 모든 가능한 오류에 대해 생각해봐요.
2^r개의 가능한 신드롬이 있고, 강의 앞에서 언급했듯이 이 신드롬들은 모든 가능한 n qubit Pauli 연산을
동일한 크기의 집합으로 분할해요. 각 집합에 4^n / 2^r개의 Pauli 연산이 있다는 의미예요.
그러므로 특정 신드롬을 보면, 이 4^n / 2^r 오류 중 어느 하나가
원인일 수 있어요. 약간 과산정하고 있긴 한데, 이 오류 중 일부는
코드 공간에 정확히 같은 효과를 갖기 때문이에요. 특히, 오류 E가 있고 E에 어떤 안정자 원소 s를 곱하면
코드 공간에서 e와 정확히 같은 효과를 갖는 또 다른 오류를 얻어요.
이것들은 동치 오류예요. 안정자에는 2^r개의 원소가 있고, 이걸 고려하면
각 신드롬에 대해 그 신드롬을 일으킬 수 있는 오류의 동치류가 4^(n-r)개 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그게 의미하는 건, r이 n과 같지 않는 한, 즉 1차원 코드 공간이 있고
qubit을 전혀 인코딩할 수 없는 경우가 아닌 한, 감지할 수 있는 모든 오류를 정정하는 게 불가능하다는 거예요.
대신에 해야 할 건 동치 오류 클래스 하나만을 정정하기 위해 각 신드롬에 대해 정정 연산 하나만을 선택하는 거예요.
그러면 각 신드롬에 대해 어떤 정정을 수행할지 어떻게 선택해야 할까요? 자연스러운 전략은
측정된 신드롬을 일으키는 가장 낮은 가중치의 Pauli 연산을 선택하는 거예요. 낮은 가중치의 Pauli 연산이 그 신드롬에 대해
더 가능한 설명을 나타낸다는 생각에서요. 일부 잡음 모델에서는 실제로 그렇지 않을 수 있고,
또 다른 자연스러운 전략은 주어진 신드롬을 일으키는 가장 가능한 오류를 어떻게든 계산하는 거예요.
하지만 지금은 신드롬을 일으키는 가장 낮은 가중치의 Pauli 연산을 선택해서 오류를 정정하려고 하는 전략만 고려할게요.
거리 D의 안정자 코드에서, 이 전략은 가중치가 D의 절반 미만인 오류, 즉 가중치가 최대 (D-1)/2인 오류를
항상 정정할 수 있게 해줘요. 간략하게 왜 그런지 설명할게요.
예를 들어, 이는 7 qubit Steane 코드가 가중치 1의 Pauli 오류를 정정할 수 있다는 걸 보여줄 거예요.
오류의 이산화에 의해, 이는 9 qubit Shore 코드처럼 Steane 코드도 하나의
qubit에서의 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있다는 의미예요. 어떻게 작동하는지 보면, 이 원이 모두 +1 신드롬을 나타내는 모든 가능한
Pauli 연산을 나타낸다고 생각해봐요. 오류가 발생하지 않았음을 시사하는 신드롬이에요.
이 연산들 중에는 안정자 원소, 더 정확히는
안정자 원소에 비례하는 연산들이 있고, 코드 공간을 어떻게든 변경하지만 코드에 의해 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류들도 있어요.
그리고 거리의 정의에 의해, 이 범주의 모든 Pauli 연산은 가중치가 적어도
D이어야 한다는 걸 알아요. D가 이 연산들의 최소 가중치로 정의되거든요. 또한 다른 신드롬을 나타나게 하는 Pauli 연산들도 있어요.
원한다면 각 신드롬을 차례로 고려할 수 있지만, 여기서는 하나의 신드롬 s가 나타났다고 가정해봐요.
이제 이 범주에서 가중치가 D의 절반 미만인 오류 e가 있다고 상상해봐요.
이 원에서 최소 가중치 Pauli 연산이 반드시 e라고 알 수는 없으니, C를 이 집합에서 최소 가중치 연산 또는 동률이 있는 경우 그 중 하나로 취해봐요.
c가 e와 같을 수도 있고 아닐 수도 있지만, C가 최소 가중치를 갖기 때문에
C도 집합에 있고 최소 가중치를 가지니, 가중치가 e의 가중치보다 클 수 없어요.
따라서 정정 연산 C는 가중치가 D의 절반 미만이어야 해요.
그러면 오류 e 발생 후 상태에 이 정정 C를 적용하면 어떻게 될까요?
답은 얻는 상태가 원래 인코딩에 C * e를 곱한 거예요. 먼저
오류인 E를 곱하고, 정정하려고 C를 곱했거든요. 이 곱은
+1 신드롬에 해당하는 집합에 있어야 해요. C와 E 모두 신드롬 s에 있어서 그 곱은 모두 +1이어야 하기 때문이에요.
이 곱의 가중치가 D보다 작다는 것도 알 수 있어요.
안정자에 있거나 안정자 원소에 비례해야 해요. 이유는 이래요. 먼저, e와 C가 같은 신드롬을 주기 때문에
C * e는 모두 +1인 신드롬을 줘야 해요. 주어진
안정자 생성자에 대해 c와 e 모두 그 생성자와 교환하거나, 모두 반교환해야 하거든요. 신드롬이 같으니까
둘 다 같아야 해요. 잠깐 생각해보면 c * e가 모든 안정자 생성자와 교환해야 한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
마지막으로 C * e는
안정자에 있어야 해요. 그 가중치는 c와 e의 가중치의 합보다 클 수 없고, 따라서 가중치가
D보다 엄격히 작아요. 이건 e를 성공적으로 정정한다는 의미예요. e에 이어 C를 적용해도
코드 공간에 아무것도 하지 않으니까요. 좋은데, 한 가지 문제가 있어요. 일반 안정자 코드에서는
주어진 신드롬을 일으키는 가장 낮은 가중치 연산을 계산하는 게 계산적으로 어려운 문제예요.
사실 고전 코드에서도 그런데, 이 맥락에서 고전 코드는 안정자 생성자 내의 텐서 인자로
단위 행렬과 Pauli Z 행렬만 나타나는 안정자 코드로 생각할 수 있어요.
따라서 인코딩 단계와는 달리 이번에는 Clifford 연산이 도움이 안 돼요. 유일하게 합리적인
해결책은 좋은 정정을 효율적으로 계산할 수 있는 특정 코드를 선택하는 거예요. 이에 대한 공식 같은 건 없어요.
간단히 말하면, 이런 안정자 코드를 고안하는 건 양자 코드 설계의 예술적인 부분이에요.
이 강의는 여기서 멈추는 게 좋겠어요. 다음 강의에서도 함께해주셨으면 해요.
다음 강의에서는 양자 코드 설계의 예술성을 꽤 멋진 방식으로 보여주는 코드들을 포함한 특정 양자 코드 구성들을 살펴볼 거예요.
지금은 여기까지예요, 안녕히 계세요.